ce n'était pas un simple accueil mais
bel et bien un accueil nationale dans
l'aérogare du lamentin parents amis
sportifs anonymes politiques mais aussi
des spiritains venus accueillir leurs
héros
aujourd'hui héros national son nom
michael laurent lui qui embrasse une
coupe presque aussi grande que lui
trophée qu'il a gagnés sur les routes
sud américaine de la guyane en déployant
une énergie qui a fait vaciller français
allemands anglais belges vénézuélien
guyanais guadeloupéens et autour de lui
séc stratège de masi fleurimont dénard
arado arcade sec comme les doigts d'une
main main qui l'a poussé jusqu'au bout
du bout maillot jaune sur le dos toute
l'équipe de travail de keep on devenait
qu'un gars costaud mais également six
points sur le leader d'enfoncer tous
investis pour la remporter
jeune immortaliser le moment hier soir
c'était aussi la soirée séance photo
avec mickaël laurent d'une timidité
inversement proportionnelle à sa
ténacité sur un cadre de vélo
hier soir c'était le temps des
félicitations d'un autre champion en
tee-shirt orange
cédric eustache maillot jaune pendant
quelques jours en guadeloupe
mais le plus heureux c'est lui alfred
defanti
lui qui garde encore des souvenirs d'un
temps que ces jeunes ne peuvent point
connaître par le temps des cerises mais
celui des peaux de banane le temps d'une
mystérieuse chute qui restera dans les
annales c'était en guyane en plateau
1978 hier soir en pensant à cayenne
c'est l'arbre n'avais plus le goût de
l'amertume
mais le goût du champagne
c'est une souffrance quand on ne sait
pas encore qu'est ce qui va se passer on
a tous laissés de côté on a laissé les
étapes on a laissé les maillots
intermédiaire pour avoir le seul
objectif c'est le maillot jaune et au
live après la stratégie vous savez c'est
des réflexes des automatismes il faut le
vivre à l'intérieur pour comprendre donc
c'est des choses qu'on peut pas
forcément écrire son papier ces choses
qu'on a dans les tripes
les martiniquais n'étaient pas les plus
forts en guyane mais les plus
intelligents les plus fins les plus fins
stratèges et c'est grâce à sa main
ses cinq coéquipiers de la sélection de
la martinique que laurent le spirit un
apu jusqu'au bout ce drapés de jaune un
taux gagner à 44 km heure de moyenne un
taux gagner sans victoire d'étape et
comme à l'image de ce dernier jo ils ont
tout contrôler ils ont su asphyxier les
meilleurs je suis content d'avoir commis
qu'elle conclut une saison 2010 y est
extraordinaire de la meilleure des
manières possibles une victoire un
nouveau titre de champion un jeu égal et
du coin en guyane peaufiner on joue
encore une de ses plus belles saisons et
qui va bientôt accoucher
je pense que la meilleure manière de
rapprocher partir en pleine gloire à 37
ans un chemin que le désormais sage
mickaël laurent envisage de masi
florimonde hainard arago à caden écrit
en guyane une nouvelle page de
l'histoire du cyclisme martiniquais et
mickaël laurent lui gagne pour la
troisième fois le tour cycliste de la
guyane